good morning cabinet thank you all very
much and very good to just to see you
all and i i think uh thank you by the
way for everybody for all your good work
yesterday because uh which was a very
important day because we're able now to
draw a line
under the issues that our opponents i
want to talk about and we are able to
get on with talking about what i think
the people in this country want us about
which is what we are doing to help them
and to take the country forward and that
is what we are going to do we're going
to focus exclusively on that and we are
helping people of course number one uh
we're dealing with the aftershocks of
kobit uh huge sums that we're putting in
uh to help cushion the inflationary
impact the rise in energy prices i think
a total of 37 billion pounds uh we've
already put in 1200 pounds for 8 million
of the most vulnerable households in the
country why are we able to to do this uh
because we took the right decisions
during kobed we came out of that
of the pandemic in a very strong
economic position unemployment the
lowest level uh since 1974 was i never
tire
of telling you and
we are going to get on with the massive
agenda that we were elected to deliver
in 2019 and it's a huge huge thing that
we're all embarked on really
transformative in infrastructure skills
and technology uniting and leveling up
across the country unleashing the
potential of the whole of the uk it is a
it is a totally morally socially
economically politically the right thing
to do and we should be proud proud
of what we're doing and there were huge
investments that we're making huge
but it's not enough just to spend money
you've got to spend it wisely
and we as conservatives and conservative
ministers have got to make sure that at
every stage we are driving reform and
driving value so what i'm going to ask
you all to do in each of your
departments is make sure that you're
thinking the whole time about cutting
the costs of government about cutting
the costs that business has to face and
of course cutting the costs uh that
everybody else faces families up and
down the country and we can all see ways
in which we can reform and improve the
way we organize things we can improv we
can change our regulations in order to
bear down on those costs whether it's in
uh in energy uh or in in transport uh in
housing one of the biggest costs
of all there is ample scope uh for us to
uh to to get out of people's way and to
to do things better and i would say
something else by the way which i think
is really uppermost in people's minds
they also want government uh to be
helping them to get the services they
need more properly
and i'm thinking particularly you know
people deserve to be able to get their
their passport or their driving license
uh just as much as they deserve to get
their their test their scan or their
screen uh on time uh promptly and we've
got to focus on that we got to make sure
that as we spend these make these
colossal investments which i i repeat i
think morally uh economically the right
thing to do we've got to get value out
of them we've got to make sure that
people see that they're getting the
services they need when they when they
want them and i think if we go forward
with that approach
continuing
to unite and level up which is a
magnificent agenda totally the right
agenda for
for the country but also driving supply
side reform driving improvement uh we
will start to see uh huge huge changes
beneficial changes in our in our economy
and uh we will have the scope
by delivering tax cuts i think uh to
deliver considerable uh growth in
employment and and uh and economic uh
and economic progress that is the that
is the way forward uh it is by making
sure that we not only continue with the
uniting leveling up agenda but we drive
supply side reform at the same time so
over the course of the next few weeks
i'm going to ask everybody uh to come
forward with ways in which we can as i
say cut costs uh drive reform and make
sure that we understand that in the end
it is it is people
who have the best feel for how to spend
their own money uh rather than uh the
government or the state and that is our
fundamental uh conservative instinct and
that way i think we will be able to get
on with our agenda making this the most
prosperous the most successful economy
in europe that's what we're going to do
thank you all for your support thank you
everything you've been doing and let's
get to it thank you
i